BEAUTIFUL SHOT OF SANTA MONICA
THERE.
WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SUNDAY
SHOW.
ONE OF THE WORLD LARGEST
AUTOMAKERS JUST ZAPPED THE LEFT
PUSH TO TRANSITION TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
CALIFORNIA'S RULE TWO AND SALES
OF GAS PER VEHICLES BY 2035, THE
PRESIDENT OF TOYOTA SAYS
"REALISTICALLY SPEAKING IT SEEMS
RATHER DIFFICULT TO REALLY
ACHIEVE THEM, BUT JUST LIKE THE
FULLY AUTONOMOUS CARS THAT WERE
ALL SUPPOSED TO BE DRIVING BY
NOW, EV'S ARE JUST GOING TO TAKE
LONGER TO BECOME MAINSTREAM IN
THE MEDIA WOULD LIKE US TO
BELIEVE".
OKAY.
WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF KYODO.
THE GRANDSON OF THE FOUNDER OF
TOYOTA.
HE MAY KNOW A THING OR TWO ABOUT
CARS, I THINK.
HE IS SAYING I DON'T THINK WE
ARE READY TO MAKE THIS
TRANSITION SO QUICKLY.
HE POINTS TO THE IMPACTS ON THE
ELECTRICAL GRID.
A LACK OF EASY ACCESS TO
ELECTRICITY.
ALL KINDS OF ISSUES THERE.
NOW THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA,
I AM SORRY, THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK IS FOLLOWING SUIT TO THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
WHEN IT COMES TO FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SUPPORTING
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION WE ARE
PUTTING THE PEDAL TO THE METAL.
SHE WANTS TO DO THE SAME THING.
BAND GAS POWERED CARS.
YOU WERE A TAXIDRIVER HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
HOW DOES THIS WORK WITH TAXIS
BEING ELECTRIC?
THERE IS NO PLACE TO EVEN PARK
IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> NO, THERE IS NOT.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE FLYING
CARS I KNOW ACCORDING TO THE
JETSONS.
THERE IS NO PRACTICAL WAY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS.
I WISH OUR LEADERS WOULD BE
HONEST ABOUT THIS.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN GREEN
ENERGY FAILED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE NOT EVEN FULLY REMOVED.
GAVIN NEWSOM IN A DOUBLE FLEECE
AND THEY ARE ICEFISHING OVER HIS
SHOULDER.
THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE RUNNING
IN THIS DIRECTION ALWAYS SPEAKS
TO THE FACT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
RAISE A LOT OF MONEY OFF OF
GREEN ENERGY.
IS IT SUSTAINABLE?
NO.
ALL OF THE GREEN ENERGY
MANUFACTURING.
IT IS A SCAM.
I DON'T BEGRUDGE ANYBODY THEIR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
I CONSIDER IT VEGAN IS A ON
WHEELS.
MIKE, NOBODY CARES.
I DO NOT THINK THERE IS ANY
WORLD WHERE THE TAXI DRIVERS
WOULD SIGN UP FOR THIS.
THERE IS NO WAY.
YOU CANNOT DO THE MILEAGE.
MOST OF THESE CARS HAVE A RANGE
OF ABOUT 200 MILES.
IN A TAXI SHIFT, IF I'M OFF THE
ROAD FOR AN HOUR OR TWO,
UNDERSTAND, LUNCH DRIVING IN A
TAXI TO TURN A PROFIT.
YOU DON'T HAVE THOSE TWO HOURS
NEVERMIND YOU WILL PROBABLY GET
JUMPED AT THE PUMP.
ANITA: OKAY.
I'VE GOT IT.
MAKING GOOD POINTS ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTIES AND LACK OF
CHARGING STATIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA WE SAW RULES
IMPLEMENTED.
YOU CANNOT CHARGE CERTAIN TIMES
OF THE DAY.
>> RIGHT.
THEY JUST SHUT DOWN THE CHARGER.
IN FLORIDA, LOUISIANA, WE HAVE
TO EVACUATE A HURRICANE, WHAT DO
WE DO?
DO WE BRING EXTRA BATTERIES?
PUT THE KIDS IN THE TRUNK?
>> YOU CAN OUT.
THE OTHER THING, THE PRICE TAG
ON THESE CARS.
$80,000 VEHICLES.
MOST MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE CANNOT
AFFORD THAT.
THE VERY IDEA THAT WE ARE
BREAKING THE MIDDLE CLASS TO DO
THIS IN THE NAME OF PROTECTING
THE ENVIRONMENT, WHAT CHARGES
THE ELECTRICAL GRID?
NATURAL GAS, COAL,
PREDOMINANTLY.
I AM SORRY, THAT IS A REALITY.
YOU SAVE NOTHING IN THIS
EXCHANGE.
EVERY TIME THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS MANDATING,
INFRINGING ON YOUR MOVEMENT,
INFRINGING ON YOUR LIBERTY.
PAIRED I THINK IT IS ALL ON
CONSTITUTION, FRANKLY.
>> THAT BRINGS UP A GOOD
QUESTION FOR LISA.
THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS, BUT,
LISA, I HAVE HEARD YOU TALK SO
OFTEN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JUST OFTEN.
>> DURING THE BREAK SHE JUST
TALKS.
>> ABOUT THE VARIOUS REASONS
PEOPLE MOVE FROM STATE TO STATE.
IS THIS ANOTHER REASON FOR
PEOPLE TO MOVE OUT OF NEW YORK
AND CALIFORNIA TO OTHER STATES
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THESE
RULES IMPOSING ON THEIR LIVES?
>> IT IS CERTAINLY ON THE LIST.
IT DOES GIVE THEM CONTROL.
WE WILL TELL YOU WHEN YOU CAN
DRIVE AND WHEN YOU CAN CHARGE
IT.
WHEN YOU CHARGE IT, YOU HAVE TO
HAVE ELECTRICITY, WHERE DOES
ELECTRICITY COME FROM?
FOSSIL FUELS.
IT WILL LEAD TO DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION.
I INTERVIEWED A GOVERNOR,
TALKING ABOUT THE POLAR VORTEX
THAT HIT SO HARD A WHILE BACK.
HE SAID COAL SAVE THE DAY.
WIND TURBINES WERE FROZEN.
COAL SAVED THE DAY.
THEY ENACTED THESE GREEN
POLICIES.
YOU HAVE 70% INFLATION IN AUGUST
THERE.
IT LEADS TO DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION.
FOSSIL FUELS LEADS TO A BETTER
LIFE FOR ALL OF US BUT I THINK
THAT IS THEIR ULTIMATE GOAL TO
BRING DEVASTATION.
IT HAS TO BE.
>> WE ACTUALLY DO NEED ELON MUSK
TO BUY TWITTER AND GIVE US BACK
FREE SPEECH.
THEY WILL REVOLT AGAINST
ELECTRIC CARS AND WE CAN GO BACK
TO GAS.
>> IT MAKES SENSE, IT IS EASY,
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> WHO CARES ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
LOOK HOW COBALT AND LITHIUM IS
MIND SPIRIT LOOK AT THE CHILDR